and shohei ohtani will take the ball
once again
for the 15th time this year
4-1 a 3-2-1 era
everybody playing tapia straight up
couldn't hold up that thing ended up
down by a shoe talk brendan rodgers now
a second baseman for the rockies
on the ground that's iglesias
such a great fielder he's unbelievable
little flip routine play
and away we go look at kerman's numbers
eight and seven
three and a half earned run average
that eats up fuentes and that's a base
hit
whoa that was a high high change up
ohtani up the middle and it rolls into
center field fletcher around
third he will score and the angels are
on the board first
not that patented exit velocity through
shohei ohtani but he gets the job
with an rbi 73 mile an hour
rbi single i think
ohtani runs walsh takes the throw
is that in time
in the right ohtani got a good jump
blackman up with it here comes ohtani
he will score
and if you're jared walsh a hit like
this
has to feel great that's a 95 mile an
hour fastball off the inside part of the
plate
still able to get enough on the
on the barrel to get that into the
outfield for an rbi single
there's show here yes the starting
pitcher already has what stolen base
rbi single what else can't show you
fletcher
out to center a slip there by marsh and
he recovers and makes the catch
in the air should be playable
for walsh joe hey otani
two scoreless in the books angels on top
two nothing airmon marquez
allowed two runs in the first inning one
unearned
bounces to first glove nope
that's chopped vermont just unable to
get to it and forces cj to do the glove
flip
oh he might have might have an argument
good look on the super super mo
he's out sorry spanky throw the
challenge flag
they did powers are reviewing it behind
no plate
jerry davis is the crew chief but jerry
says you
are out top of the fourth and charlie
blackman will
go against shohei ohtani
this is iglesias all the way from short
who gets the flip
walsh secures it
[Applause]
look out that comes up and in and hit
him on the left hand and trevor
trots his way down that third baseline
towards the coaching box he
is in some pain
it's just a 4c fastball never had a
chance
squared up the hand
is he staying in wow
so the rocky's trying to figure out
shohei ohtani
as dom hits it high and deep to right
field did he get enough of it to
the wall goes eaton it is out of here
touch him all time for dom nunez
number six and the rockies
are on the board it's a 2-1 game
rocky's catchers this year from elias
diaz to dom nunez now
all of a sudden you have 15 home runs
behind the play not bad
this is rogers second baseman up the
middle
iglesias has it fumbles it bounces it
got him looking at that one too
just to make sure david fletcher got to
the bag
this bobble on the transfer
that's gonna be close i think there's a
good chance that's gonna be overturned
that's a little different angle where
the foot is up in the air just enough
yeah his foot didn't hit the front of
the bag it hit the top of the bag
that may save the angels in that one
angle he looks like he beat it the other
angle
we're gonna find out he's out
[Applause]
ramon marquez wasn't sharp in the first
since then he's looked a lot better
he's given up just one hit since that
first inning
good pitch slider strikes out jack
mayfield
this is wide to left and tapia will run
it down
good running cast here
1-2 pitch is hit right into the shift
second baseman rogers has got it
throws out ohtani another solid inning
for airmon marcus
angels are leading the rockies 2-1 iran
marquez has allowed two runs
one earned in his five innings
[Applause]
and another strikeout
the glaciers was ahead 2-0 now he has to
make a left turn
they are in san diego next that ball's
in the gap left center field
hilliard after it wallish around second
ball is dropped
walsh arrives at third and that is a
sweet spot
for marsh that left center gap he's been
all over that
here's the one-two fastball see you
later
wow showed up at the right time a little
traffic
no problem strikeout number eight
tonight for herman
and it's a 2-1 game shohei ohtani into
the seventh
against the colorado rockies 3-2
got him
fourth strikeout oh that was a nasty
[Applause]
slider
not hit that well marsh covers a lot of
ground
1-2 fastball 100
and 1-2-3 go the rockies 100 mile an
hour fastball are you kidding me
that's his best pitch tonight eaton
survives it first mayfield's at the
plate
mayfield left field down the line
carrying
and god just got out
to run shots jack mayfield
again captain of captain jack
hard foul the ball off your foot you
know the best way to
make sure that doesn't bother anymore is
go yard and then
job jose quintana
last two games in relief good three two
thirds he's not giving up an earned run
hasn't walked anybody
rogers leans on one to dead center and
he clicks this one
sixth home run of the year for brendan
rodgers it's four to two
inside out got the barrel to it he's so
quick to the baseball
rogers doing right off the bat don't
blame him that's
five six rows back
this ball lined with authority to deep
right and it's
gonna hop out of play which is a
bad break for the rockies because
charlie would have scored easily
[Applause]
right center field and deep marsh
track wall got it
five to two the score first and third
adam eaton coming up against zach ross
cup
3-2 high in the right
remember there's one out marsha's
tagging blackman has it here comes marsh
here comes a throw he is safe
hair flowing helmet flying goslin is
thrown out at second base
well on the mound for the angels is
closer reichel
iglesias and the one-two
got him ball game angels
take the opener of this three-game set